- My next guests are WWE Superstars
who are scheduled to be inducted
into the WWE Hall of Fame
this year, awesome!
They have a new book out
called "Incomparable"
and they're the stars of the
reality show "Total Bellas"
on E!
Take a look.
- Are you guys ready?
- [Bearded Man] Yeah.
- [Woman] We're ready.
- [Crowd] 10, nine, eight, seven, six,
five, four, three, two, one.
(crowd cheering)
(exciting music)
- All right, Brie and Nikki Bella,
are you there?
- Hey.
- Hi. Oh my gosh, y'all are
so beautiful, good gosh.
You're actually goddesses,
and it's like...
Well it is lovely to meet y'all,
thank you so much for
hanging with me on my show.
And congrats, so to you both.
Twins having babies at the same time,
you obviously planned that?
Like--
- No, how crazy is that.
- Wait, you didn't plan it?
- [Nikki] No.
- No.
We actually both were
surprised by our pregnancies.
- So, Brie found out first
and she was already set on one,
like she has a little girl
and it took her a while.
They tried for a while for baby number two
and then they were just set like,
we're meant to have one kid.
And I had just gotten
engaged and I was like,
well, I'm not gonna have kids for years
and it'll probably be just one.
I'll be you know, in my 40s
and just do the one.
And then she came to me and
told me she was pregnant
and I was just so shocked
because I knew like, I was like,
were you guys trying?
Like, what was it?
And then two days later,
I started to feel symptoms
but I'm thinking it's my twin like
it's a twin thing.
- It's twin thing.
- But I was like, I'm
just gonna take a test
and I saw positive and I
was like there is no way
and I took another test a week later
'cause then I was late
and we're a week and a 1/2 apart.
- We're like, someone up there has a plan.
- Yeah.
- A week and a 1/2 apart unplanned,
I mean I guess you can't
really plan it in general
'cause you never know
when that's gonna happen.
But that's insane.
- [Brie] Yeah.
- I just never heard anything like that,
that's crazy.
- We literally just got
back from our doctors,
and you know, right now
because of everything,
you know, you have to,
your spouse can't come
with you or your loved one.
But we're lucky that
we're pregnant together,
we get to go together so
our doctor always sees us
at the same time, we
do everything together.
- Yeah.
- Our baby had the exact
same heart rate today.
- What?
- I mean, it's weird.
- Yeah.
- It's like (mumbles).
- It's the coolest thing.
That's just such a cool
thing that does not happen
to anyone.
So, that's, I mean, it's already special
you're already twins, it's
just like double special.
Brie, how did you keep, I mean,
'cause you also have a three year old,
like how did you keep your
three year old entertained?
I did see a photo of you
guys dressed as robots,
which was awesome.
- You know, it's funny because
I feel like all parents
it's like, everyday my biggest challenge
is keeping my toddler entertained
and at the same time I wanna
make her brain work, yeah.
And so, she just kept
pointing at this robot
in this book.
And so I was like, you know what?
Right now we're all
getting so many boxes sent
to out front door, I should
just use these boxes,
use my leftover gift wrapping
and just make robots.
- Yeah.
- And I did and it was
actually really fun for me.
I did it during her nap time
and I actually was so into it.
But now, we have a robot outfit
which just takes up
more space in the house,
but we love it.
We get in them and she...
- And what was so cute
is when she got in them,
she asked us like where is the popcorn?
- We're like, popcorn?
So I realized from the
book the robot always
has like held a popcorn.
- Always held popcorn.
- So she's--
- Yeah, you're like you
didn't nail this costume.
- Yeah. Where is popcorn mom, come on.
- Which is probably why
she likes the robot,
'cause she's like, wait, I get popcorn.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] (mumbles)
it's mac and ball, yeah.
- You're smart.
- So Nikki, I mean, speaking of books
your new book, gets pretty deep
into your tough upbringing, right?
So was it hard to relive
some of those stories?
I can't, you know, people
have always asked me
about writing a book about my life
and I'm just not there yet, like I just,
there is a lot of stuff I
think I'm working through.
Like, was that hard?
- It was definitely hard.
You know, for Brie and I,
we've been in and out of therapy
since we've been 15 years old.
And...
But then we became apart
of the WWE universe
and then we're on reality TV
and we had this fandom
called the Bella Army.
And we became very intimate with them,
like, we were very inspired
and motivated by their stories
and how they were motivated by us
and so when we were approached
about doing an autobiography,
we were like, well you know what?
If we do this, we want it to be a memoir
and we want it to be that when you close
that last page, that you
take something from it.
That it's not just about our achievement
and just about life but
Brie and I go to a place
that, where people look at us as victims
but how we truly, cause we had each other,
we made ourselves be survivors.
And even you know, for
me, I shared a few stories
that I had never shared
even with my own mother.
My mum didn't even know about
it till the book came out
because I still didn't have
the confidence to tell her
that I was raped twice
in high school and--
- That is a really
rough thing for your mum
to probably hear to, you know, not know.
- She's, it was a very
emotional week for us
and it was like, even
when we wrote the book,
it was like constant being back in therapy
but what I've realized is like
women and girls and even men and boys,
like they need those role models
to be confident to talk about
what they're going through
because what I've realized,
is when I've held on
to things for over 20 years,
it doesn't help you grow as a human being.
And we really have to,
yeah, have that confidence
to speak out and that's
what Brie and I said.
We, let's put it all out there
because so many people
are gonna relate to this
and living in this filter
world of social media,
people know that, need to know that
there's people in the spotlight
that they could be like,
whoa, they went through that
and look at where they got.
And we truly wanted people to heroes
of their own stories.
- I agree, and I think because
there is such a high rise
of just you know, all
these social platforms,
that we lose human connection
and story and just examples
and Nicole and I were just like,
you know what?
If there are people who've gone through
like you know, we had a really rough
childhood with our father
and just Nicole's experience
in high school and mine.
If there is people out there
who are doing it alone,
or at least our story is to let them know
that they're not alone and
that there is light at the end
of the tunnel.
- Yeah.
Hey, thank you guys.
Like, for one, being great examples
for little girls and then also for
being that vulnerable,
'cause that's not an easy place to be
especially in the public eye.
So thank you so much
for hanging out with me
and congratulations.
Okay, we're gonna take a break,
but y'all the Bella
twins' new book is called
"Incomparable" and it's
in stores right now
and you never know how it
can help you change your life
and impact you, so check it out.